Thierry bed
your candidate for the 2022 legislative elections
for the animalist party
in the fourth district of the oise
I am Turkish
I am the founder of an association
who administers a shelter
and throughout my career
I found that
despite the words despite perhaps the impression
who would be given today
more consideration for animals in France
the reality is quite different there is always
every year more and more cruelty
more and more abuse
that are committed on animals
is to defend them
is for this cause
which is shared by almost all French people
which is really a consensual cause
is finally taken into account
considered each animal as an individual
that elisa and I present ourselves
for the 2022 legislative elections
in the fourth district of the oise
for the animalist party
vote for us
it means giving yourself the means that finally
deceased persons
seriously concerned about the condition of animals
can represent you
and represent the defense of animals
as a real political cause
it's serious
I am elisa gorins
I am a substitute candidate
in the legislative elections
I am not originally from the oise
I am originally from the Hauts de Seine but for all that
I believe that the goose has a very important role to play
I think it can be the engine of France
because Oise is an extremely rich department
culturally
on a historical level
environmentally and this
are so many subjects
that we want to wear with thierry bedossa
if you do us the honor
if you trust us
then we can represent you
represent all those who love animals
all those who want action and change
and all those who are convinced
that it is by saving the animals
that we can save ourselves
in 2022 the dogs will be at the national assembly
vote for us vote for the animal rights party thank you